[Music]
hey doug welcome to the show
hi rachel thank you for taking my call
today how are you we're doing well
thanks so much how can we help
so i think i kind of have a bit of an
issue on baby step two i feel like i'm
just on a like a debt treadmill where
the process is just never ending and it
seems like no matter what i do
to get out of it i always kind of just
slump right back into it and i think it
might be something psychological that i
just can't quite figure out and i was
curious to see if you'd be able to help
me with that yeah absolutely okay so
give me a little bit of background like
how much debt how much did you have left
what's been what's been your journey
what's caused you to go back in
i mean it's always just a really small
amount of credit card debt i don't have
any student loans i don't have any car
payments or
anything like that and every once in a
while i'll find myself getting into a
hole of about three to four thousand
dollars in credit cards and i sit there
and tell myself you gotta be kidding me
i can't keep doing this you know if i
wanna
make it through this and make it through
the baby steps i think this is kind of
just where i'm having my issue
what's causing you to swipe the credit
cards is it emergencies that happen is
it impulse purchases what's the thing
that's driving that three to four
thousand
in credit card debt constantly
i think it might be impulses and things
that i tell myself could be emergencies
that that aren't emergencies if i go out
and
i'm doing something and
you know buying something that i
shouldn't we're saying hey there's these
new shoes they're really cool i need
those
so i just think it's a lot of impulses
and a lot of things like that um
that's that's causing that
so i i want you to would you be willing
to try something new
of course okay um two things i want you
to try new
one i want you to look at this not as
you're a loser and a failure and an
idiot
but i want you to look at this as an
environmental issue okay
is that cool yeah because you're in a
system now that you've created for
yourself you've just created a loop for
yourself where you do this thing and
then you feel like crap about it and
then you white knuckle your way through
it for a minute and then
you feel
a little bit better and then you go do
it again and the whole loop starts over
again right
you're just like on one of these like
kids like train tracks
so
let's stop beating up on doug number one
number two
change your environment get rid of all
of your cards
cancel amazon prime make it almost
freaking impossible for you to do this
so for me i am a raging sugar addict
comically so like my friends make fun of
me it's it's ridiculous my kids make fun
of me it's like gummy it's gross stuff
it's not even good yes it's not even
like a snickers it's like a sour patch
yeah it's just gross it's it's it's like
a main line how
like yes yes i may have snorted sugar
before so listen so listen i have to
have a home that doesn't have any of
that in it and my wife like when i'm out
of town my wife and kids they have like
they go get ice cream and it's like it's
it's an enjoyable time for them i had to
create an environment where i don't even
have access to it which then gave me
time to
let that addiction simmer and stop and
then i can re-enter the world does that
make sense
yeah that makes a lot of sense actually
and what i would tell you is until
you're ready to change the environment
you're not ready to stop spending and to
truly get out of debt and those are the
two like those first two things doug
like what john was saying is spot on and
then even when you're out of it and
you're kind of in a in a better
habit of okay i'm not going into debt
for the stuff because i don't have the
ability to i have no i have no credit
cards i'm not being myself up but then
go into the practice because even when
you become healthier with money i think
still asking the question
why am i wanting to spend this money
that's right what is it is it because
it's going to make me feel good in the
moment because i'm sad or i'm depressed
or i'm discouraged or i'm bored
or is it because i feel bad about myself
and this thing's going to make me feel
better because i'll get compliments from
it like like find that root too because
again buying stuff is is not the issue
it's why you're doing it it's kind of
that underneath jug is what john's kind
of getting out as well so and i i have
found working with people who struggle
with addiction
you ca i ca i let me just talk about
myself i can't make that change in that
environment yeah i can i can't be
surrounded by bags of marshmallows and
and gummy candies
as i'm shoveling them in going i wonder
while i'm doing it yep i need to have a
clear slate so then when i feel the
impulse i can then stop and say
what am i hiding from here what is my
body trying to protect me from yeah and
that's the same with alcohol and
pornography all the things right
spending here i love that clear the deck
and then begin to feel your body begin
to ask why am i leaning into this why am
i trying to cover something up what is
it i'm trying to cover up yeah and and
just the in the spending in general in
life in our country today is so normal
you know consumerism is like at an
all-time high and so what are the things
even if you're even if you're someone
listening and you're not doug and you're
like i'm not going deep in credit card
debt there are still things that i even
put in place as a natural spender i know
myself and even on baby step seven even
though we may even have it in the budget
i still feel convicted at times of like
why am i really doing like what is why
am i spending this and so i unsubscribe
from emails all the time i'll go back
through because
sugar's your thing clothes are mine i
love shopping it's just my thing but
i'll go through and i'm like okay i'm
going to unsubscribe from all these
emails because every time there's a sale
anytime there's anything it pops up in
my gmail account and i'm like oh my gosh
there it is i never would have known
that existed on instagram i unfollow
people not because they're terrible and
evil but for me i'm like
everything that she posts i want and i'm
like you know what just give just just
it's just a click away it's just a click
away and then i never save passwords i
never try to save my debit card
information website i need to have to
relog in
start from scratch everything you're
like i gotta go find the car i got it
and it gives this friction
in our purchasing as well which i think
is really i think it's huge again
whether you're like doug and you're like
oh my gosh i just seem to keep going
into it but even if you're not i think
it's just a good practice
to slow down and ask the questions okay
what why why am i needing this why do i
feel like i want to buy it and you just
don't something important the
companies don't make things convenient
because they're your friend
they make it convenient because you're
more likely just to stumble in and hit
by now by now by now so again i'm the
same as you i have to set
the fourth of july thing came through in
this like the 24 hour flash sale and i
was with some a buddy in the middle of
nowhere and he's like oh i gotta get on
live
it was so annoying
having to re-log in and learn a new
thing and punch it
but i have to set those brakes for
myself otherwise i'm just buying this
bag and buying this thing and i need
this new whatever and it's yeah it just
gets out of control for me yeah it's a
are you a more natural saver spender oh
my gosh all right spender oh
why did i
why did i ask that that was a moment
where uh
direct deposit actually helped me
because
i would go to the bank and cash my check
and it would never make it home so
actually
by my company sending my check directly
to the bank
they take me out of the equation it
actually helps me out